-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, we do this thing
every week where I send out
a hashtag and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, I sent out
the hashtag #TextFail,
and I asked you guys
to tweet out your weird,
funny, or embarrassing
text-message stories.
Within minutes, it was a
trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We do it every week.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
text fail tweets from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one is
from @JakeWilliamsArt.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Me there soon."
-Like a caveman.
-Yeah.
-"Wondering on eat."
"Eat soon."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Hasmigkt.
She said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-This one's from @soulsto1.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one.
-Genius!
-Quick thinking.
-Oh, my God.
-Quick, qu-- yeah.
Quick thinking.
"Look at this.
This is what
our friendship has --"
-"What happened to us?
How ridiculous."
-"Acting like fools."
[ Laughter ]
-"You're right, you're right."
-This one's from
@KerryM McCarthy.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @gumgumerson.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, we love gum gumerson.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He says...
Hey.
[ Laughter ]
[ Funk music plays ]
-Sugar.
-Yeah.
This one's from Lenemachine25.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
Not bad.
-Come on.
-This one's from @matthewdietz7.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sugar buns.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from --
-[ Laughs ]
-This one's
from @melissa newell.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "What's your problem?
We all wished you happy --
sang happy birthday to --
Oh, wrong house."
This one's from @RiveraDanimal.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Oh, geez."
-This one's rough.
-This is a ro-- oh.
-Yeah.
This one's from @MegLew75.
She said...
[ Laughter ]
There you have it.
Oof!
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.